hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar chemical cytoprotection for
stress-free use of human stem cells in
basic and translational research
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by namasel
to learn more visit namasell.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr elias singech director stem cell
translation laboratory
nih regenerative medicine program
dr singet you may now begin your
presentation
all right
thank you very much for the kind
introduction and i would also like to
thank um the organizers for giving me
the opportunity uh to present you today
really a great pleasure
so um
what i want to talk to you today about
is
covered in this slide here um so
essentially two parts
of my presentation so the first part i
want to introduce you to a
a new approach um how to culture
and utilize ips cells so this is a
strategy or polypharmacology strategy
that we call the set cocktail
i will touch on how we
develop this small molecule cocktail
give you some insights on mechanisms of
action and also point out some
examples that should um
show you some of the routine
applications we're using this strategy
for
so then in the second part of the talk i
will
focus on
an important uh topic which is single
cell cloning of human stem cells and
highlight um
a few examples and then
explain a little bit more why this is so
important for the stem cell field in
particular
um so first of all um
so give you a little bit more background
on
the group that we started six years ago
at the national center for advancing
translation sciences
ncats this is part of
nih um so the original um question
that we wanted to address is how can we
help to bring the ipsco technology into
clinical applications so this is what
i'm
showing here on the left-hand side as
innovative stem cell technologies
um so questions around quality control
safety standards uh can we develop more
efficient
and more reproducible cell
differentiation protocols uh
comprehensive cell characterization
using multi-homic technology and also
discovery of new small molecules that we
think is important in this context
the second area the group is working on
is called
niho initiative so heo stands for
helping to end addiction long term
this was started in
response to the opioid crisis
and the goal is to develop
new drugs for pain addiction and opioid
use disorder
using cell derived cell types then
there's a third category where we have
ongoing projects around
public health emergencies and
areas of unmet medical needs so we have
ongoing
projects around zika virus developing
drugs against
coronavirus and then also some
interest in rare diseases
so
one of the first questions we ask
ourselves six years ago was
a long-standing
challenge in the stem cell fields how
can we improve cell viability
and this is a question this goes back
all the way to the first isolation of
human embryonic stem cells in 1998
by jamie thompson and colleagues
and and uh essentially still we're
dealing with this problem and
this means that
human embryonic stem cells as well as
ips cells discovered uh later
are inherently sensitive cell types
uh so we know that special media coding
substrates and um
special culture conditions are required
to keep these cells growing
so we know that these cells are
undergoing replicative stress
they have a unique
way of replicating a shortened g1 phase
in the cell cycle
and also it is important to keep these
cells growing in a safe
avoiding
accumulation of karyotypic abnormalities
um and and since 2007 we know
um
that using um inhibitors of the rock
pathway
uh so this is a paper that was published
by um yoshiki sasai and colleagues in
2007 and this is still one of the
standard ways of culturing
political and stem cells so using
this approach uh
y27632 in particular to
improve cell survival
so this is the current state and we
wanted to um revisit this question and
um took an approach
um using high profit screening um this
is done in
uh in highly miniaturized 15 36 well
plates as shown here on the left hand
side
so initially we used 500 cells per well
and found
113 hits
then went on
performed combinatorial matrix screening
and then found two compounds and then we
continued this
as the goal was we need to
improve also single cell cloning
and as you may know there is an inverse
correlation between cell density and
self stress as you reduce the number of
cells your increasing this amount of
stress in these cultures so hence we
screened um
later on at 10 cells parallel
and and this led us to
those four compounds that we call set uh
so sep stands for chrome and juan
ambika-san
polyamines and trans-israel
i want to give you um
a few examples of why this is uh this
turned out to be really important this
combination of four factors so first of
all um in the first screen
uh we discovered as i mentioned 113 hits
among those were 20
rock kinase inhibitors like y27 632 that
i just mentioned
but also others like pinoccidillo
italian surviving others that were have
been reported previously
but it turned out that one compound
called called chrome and one
stood out in that it was more potent
than the other compounds
and and also
um in direct comparison to um the widely
used y27 compound
now we're using a hotspot kinase essay
looking at um
369 um
kinases in the human genome so it turned
out that chromin one at just 50
nanomolar is not only more potent than
10 micromolar y27 compounds
but also we found that um
y27 actually inhibits
protein kinase c isoforms so they are
off target effects whereas chromosomal
one
is more potent as well as more selective
so this is really important going
forward
to use the best
in class rock kinase inhibitor
so
as i mentioned in the in the continuous
screening
approach another compound turned out to
synergize with chroma one
so this is ambi cassan pancas phase
inhibitor
and in these experiments we show that
the combination of crowman
juan and emmy cassandra is superior to
chrome and one alone or y27
alone
and using now various um
essays we can demonstrate that this is
truly um
a synergistic effect
and has
superior effects compared to the single
agent treatment
so
however if we um
now tried uh single cell coding
experiments the the effect was not
really
that convincing to us so we thought we
can
do better as we uh continue
to screen for additional compounds and
in this experiment in panel b
as you see that the combination of
chromium 1 and ricasson and the third
compound this turn out to be trans
israel
has has additional
synergistic effects
as we demonstrate here and transducer
helps cells to continue approaching
translation
this is otherwise compromised when cells
are stressed and
upon single-cell dissociation
so um
then
just to quickly give you um
some some background information on the
polyamons uh to polyamines um these are
represented by patricians bermudin and
uh you may know that these um molecules
support various functions in cells
they're essential
but in this
context they they help cells to attach
so this is something we're showing here
on the left hand side with impedance
analysis
and again systematic comparison to um
single agent treatment or combination
with two or three compounds you see
against septus superior under the right
hand side an assay that shows again that
sept
um
is is superior in promoting protein
translation under these conditions so
altogether um so justifying why we think
that um
this four um
parts uh small molecule a cocktail is
still superior so moving on a few
examples of how sept works
on the mechanistic level
so in panel a you see
in comparison so just the mso treatment
because of cell contractions
using a reporter cell line you actually
see how
the nucleus is is really compromised so
cells continue to contract
with y27 you see more normal more
circular
uh nuclei
but again with sept we see it's it's um
better
um so we don't see these constrictions
that you still can detect with confocal
microscopy y27
so this all published data i don't want
to
go into all the details but the point
here is really that
with western blotting for instance in
panel e
you see that
stress pathways are less active in the
presence of sap and these are
single cell dissociated pluton stem
cells
early after
packaging so three hours in this case in
panel e and for instance atf4 is a
master regulator of um
of cellular stress is active in dmso and
y27
conditions but not when septus
applied to these cells then other
examples where we demonstrate uh for
instance in panel g graphing levels
remain higher
in the presence of step so essentially
less oxidative stress on these cells
and also structural proteins and panel
age remain higher so these are membrane
associated proteins
uh higher in the presence of sat
so um one important
finding in this study is that
even in during routine cell passaging
so we see a science of of dna double
strand breaks so this is shown here with
the comet assay and we're using now
um
various other um commercially available
reagents like clone r divider cell
and directly comparing to sept
at six hours post passaging and you see
that only saps on this assay
prevents
dna double string breaks
so moving on and and demonstrating that
um
the presence of seth is is really
protecting the cell it's not masking
any effects so stress is simply not
happening or is being prevented
so we use etopocites so to cause damage
in the presence of sap and demonstrate
that cellular stress response is still
possible in the presence of sap so again
making the case that uh we're not
masking this effect but it's a true
cytoprotective effect
so as a quick summary
um
i want to
show this
summary here so so essentially sap is a
new chemical cycle protection approach
uh cells are more sensitive than we
thought previously um
this approach really maintains
structural and functional integrity
and um and you have to um
keep in mind two important stem cells
are self-renewing repeated
passaging steps um involving
um induction of cellular stress and we
think that this approach uh we have a
good handle on potentially
um reducing the the probability of
accumulating karyotypic abnormalities in
these cell lines
that are being passage for
sometimes for many years as you as you
as you know
um again this is uh published data and
on the left hand side you see the
stressed cells and on the right hand
side
um except protecting
stress so moving on um
giving you some examples of how sept can
be useful for
basic research as well as
application of ips cells
so we have done extensive studies on um
characterizing cells after long-term
culture
incept so this is again
only during the passaging step uh just
for 24 hours uh cells are exposed to sap
and then you remove that
and uh
and the sunlines remain carry typically
normal they express the typical uh
pluripotency associated um
transcription factors shown here
like nano before sucks ii and others
um so we also used whole exome
sequencing to make sure that
there are no um
uh
changes occurring in terms of uh snips
cancer hot spots in del's
ongoing studies where we're repeating
these experiments with uh whole genome
sequencing
so this is um
going to be the separate uh future study
to really make the point that sept can
help with
avoiding
genetic abnormalities so
we also use sets
in our robotic cell culture
strategies
so in this case um we're using a
platform called compact select t
and um
so again
the the
superior effects of sept allow us to
allow us to do these experiments in a
more standardized a more controlled
fashion
um so there's a paper in press um this
should be out next month uh describing
how we use set in the context of
automated um
cell culture along with industrial scale
um
biomanufacturing
and um this is the example here
um so in just 12 days we are able to
generate over 9 billion ipscs um as i'm
showing here
on the right hand side
so again
the major problem in the stem cell field
how to
handle multiple cell lines how to
generate sufficient cellular material
later for clinical application and this
is basically a proof of principle type
of study
demonstrating this
so
another study that is currently under
review we have developed a new protocol
that allows us to
different shapes um human stem cells
first into radial glial cells
and then we can skip neurogenesis and
then
generate astrocytes directly in in about
30 days
and the use of cepts again helps us to
scale up
astrocytes so we generate
approximately 500 million astrocytes
that can be cryopreserved
using saturn
and um
also important in this context is scale
throughput screening
want to generate sufficient numbers um
on the defined conditions
and this is again now possible with
using sap so our experiments are more
predictable
we've taken out the uh the guesswork
can generate neurons hepatocytes and
cardiomyocytes
as demonstrated in the study
so um a quick reminder that sept is also
um the key for
helping cells uh
with with crime preservation and falling
um this uh study again
published um just want to highlight that
um crypt preservation we used three
different
reagents and freezer y27 632 and sat
and then using now
again various other uh reagents
side by side and and in each case
accept the superior and we are
showing this with five different cell
lines
and and the following process in
particular is where you have the most
significant variation
so it really doesn't matter if you cry
preserve an m-freezer a y-27 or sep but
the the following process is key
but for consistency reasons we
essentially use
step for cryo preservation as well as
throwing
um
we have
shown in other independent experiments
that you can simulate
a cell shipment in this case
you're using different cell lines and
astrocytes and again
uh putting cells for 20 to 72 hours on
dry ice for instance
and then following them and using them
you see again uh cept has superior
effects
um
another example um is the formation of
embryo bodies this is a widely used
assay in the stem cell field
uh to generate um
germ layer cells so representing
ectoderm endoderm and mesoderm
and in panel a you see uh in bulk
culture experiments sept generates um
most numerous
numbers of embryo bodies to do this with
a defined number of cells generate
single
m rate bodies per valve
in panel b you see this also nicely um
really minimizing uh the the amount of
um
that cells shown in panel c with propio
propidium iodide
and calcium used here as
a dye indicating life cells
so again
an important application that we can
improve by using sept
additional experiments were done in this
case
looking actually at this differentiation
of
excuse me single embryo bodies
and as you see here um so the the number
of um emirate bodies so in this case
again a very
um
significant effect that sep generates
embryo bodies that express um
genes of the three germ layers so sox17
for endoderm x6 for ectoderm and
brachyury for mesoderm
so this is a tricky assay we developed
using qpcr and then
you don't get really much material out
of single american bodies but
nevertheless this was um
a clear trend showing um
superior facts except
um
so this goes on now um and we
demonstrate uh sept improves um also
organoid formation
we have used a standardized kit
just simply replaced um
y27632 with sept and and again you see
um just this 24-hour treatment at the
very beginning
involving an android body formation step
you see again um
this has long lasting effects so day 60
um all
cerebral
organoids are larger shown here
uh in these macroscopic
images
interestingly um
comparing
using rna-seq
for comparison you you also see
um that the cells
in these ebs
or organoids treated with different
shades better
um
and and are less variable so this is
shown on the right hand side less
variation and improving the role of the
sensation as we compare this to
individual data sets
so
similar
observations when a kidney organic
formation kit is used again replacing
y27
with sept um larger organoids more
numerous organics this is particularly
obvious when you reduce the number of
cells
when starting this
this organoid formation effect
so
as i mentioned previously so
cryopreservation following with septum
superior this is again shown here an
independent experiment a to c
the reason i'm showing this slide is in
the lower panel in d
uh we found also that
cells
so commercially available cells
or in-house generated um pesticides in
this case
benefit from
cryopreservation and thawing recept
so we think this the fact that scept has
on itself is not just restricted on
ips cells but more broadly
applicable
um
this is also confirmed independently by
collaborators um the national heart lung
heart lung and blood institute so core
facility that is uh specialized on
making
uh cardiomyocytes from ips cells and and
our colleagues
um have shown that um receptors again
superior
uh when cardiomyocytes are um thought in
the present set
so um i want to shift gears now and um
focus on single cell cloning
um so many of you may know that single
cell cloning is really an important
assay in stem cell biology
it has been hampered for many years
uh due to the fact that
stem cells are
sensitive cells to single cell
dissociate them
you lose the community effect and cells
are more prone to undergo apoptosis
um and it is also true that single cell
cloning is the most stringent experiment
to demonstrate stemness so really
analyzing the progeny of a single sound
you need this type of assay
we think standardization and controlling
cellular heterogeneity
is important in this context quality
control of cell lines so can we
generate cell lines
from the very beginning
and controlling
that it's a clonally established line
um so this is important also for
streamlined
and safe genome editing
so this is otherwise very complicated
and
time-consuming to really find the
correctly edited cell and then to to
establish the lines
um including reporter cell lines
isogenic cell lines
this is important in the context of
disease modeling
phenotyping
but but also in the
future applications of cell and gene
therapy
so you need to find a way of improved
single cell cloning
and doing this in a safe um and
efficient
conditions and and also what we think um
the production of next generation ips
alliance so cell lines that from the
very beginning
are treated in the best possible
way using a cytoprotective effect like
like sepsis is providing
so um
first of all um so looking at
the early time point of ips cell
association so what we found is
even in the presence of
y27632 on the left hand side you see
still
cells are contracting
so you see these um
abnormal
morphologies and then within the
presence of fat even
at this early time point you will find
more often cells with more circular
um
morphology so so again
circularity in this case or roundness
indicates cells are
are not stressed so that they're not
undergoing cell contractions
so so done not more systematically in
panel a uh comparing
and including clone r is another reagent
and we see this
again uh
as shown in panel b uh sept
protects themselves they're more round
and circular
they also attach better in the in the
presence of sets as i've mentioned
before
shown here in penalty again
um
and and now um
what we tried to do is really find
the most optimal way of
performing single cell cloning
and and after testing several approaches
including fact sorting and other
technologies
um we decided that um
we need something that is aminable for
high throughput applications and and
something
technology that is uh
and and uh helps us to dispense cells
in a gentle way
uh and this is
possible with with this uh instrument
shown here
it's the hana from ammo cell
that we're now routinely using
uh in combination with the sap cocktail
and um
so one approach of doing it is um
we can pre-label cells so using calcium
to make sure that um we only
dispense of life cells
and and this is again shown in a b and c
and and a typical example
is shown in panel d where you have one
single cell
and and and then you follow the cell
over time the time that's time lapse for
video microscopy and you see
a single um
clone
emerging
and then this clone can then be
further
propagated and you establish
quickly
a cell line
another example shown here in panel a
in this case we waited for
nine days
um so alkaline phosphatase is a marker
for pull upon stem cells
and uh
in the
direct comparison we see
sept
promotes higher cloning efficiency shown
in panoxy
and also
cell clonal cell lines maintain normal
karyotypes so these are eight different
uh clonal cell lines that we've
established
they are normal and they're currently
undergoing
as mentioned whole genome sequencing
so a summary slide
of how to achieve robust and scalable
signal cell cloning
um so we can pre-label cells or we can
take them
in their native condition we can load
them into
these microfluidic chips
and then quickly dispense cells into 96
well plates or 384 well plates
and then simply track sounds over time
so typically
after a week or so you um you can
identify identify these
clones
that can be picked again in the presence
of saps
optimizing this procedure
and then really quickly establish clonal
cell lines
that then can further be tested for
pluripotency
genomic analysis single cell analysis
drug screening disease modeling etc
so um really a a workflow that has been
for many years very difficult to to
implement and achieve and this we think
will now
allow many groups um
to establish truly uh truly
true clonal cell lines
and and this process can be
better controlled all together
um and again it's not just establishing
coronal cell lines
the point is from the very beginning
to to protect ourselves from cellular
stress and repeated cellular stress is
as i mentioned um
really
a challenge a long standing challenge in
the field
so
one other
area that is
improved by using sept is
electroporation
so this technology
is um is important as we are
performing
uh genome editing experiments
and you see a nicely in the
quantification
using three different cell lines in the
upper panel and then also
in the lower panel showing the
microscopic images and 24 hours after
electroporation
that that cells survive better they
morphologically
are in better shape compared to y27
so
the as a summary of everything i've been
um talking about today
so we think cept can serve as an
end-to-end solution with safe and
efficient
ips subculture
so from the very beginning we generate
ips cells you're using sets
consistently
at each passage
so routine passaging should be done in
cept
if you decide to cry preserve cells
if you differentiate them and generate
neurons cardiomyocytes other cell types
we can use sept and we also have
uh shown in the published
paper that
cells recover faster from falling
and are more functional um a few days
later
as we would prefer
um single-cell cloning i've shown you
the example with um mammal cells hana
instrument
uh gene editing so there's a separate
study ongoing that um
also will
further show that gene editing itself is
promoted by sept
the cells are
basically not
stressed twice by the single cell
dissociation procedure and then again
by introducing
cat9 which which then again introduces
dna double string breaks
i
demonstrated
that every bodies
benefit from sep treatment and then also
organoids
uh cerebral organics and
kidney organoids as examples
and we think this is again a more
generalizable
approach
including for other sensitive cell types
um
this is particularly important as we
want to develop these technologies into
for clinical applications
um
so so next generation ips aligns and
then
using the most optimal conditions um
growing and
differentiating these cells
and um
and lastly um i want to highlight
that um it turned out that the four
components of set
are
cheaper than the other reagents um that
are currently available
and this is important because in this
case uh it's not only the better method
but also
more cost efficient this is again
important for
uh large-scale um high-throughput
applications so this was
surprising to us to see this after
completing the study and and really
uh
good to know that yeah there's this
alternative reset
so i want to thank um
my colleagues at nih
this
work has been funded by nih common funds
this is a funding mechanism coming
from the nih director's office dr
francis collins
um many other colleagues who have been
supporting and providing feedback on
the many other projects we have ongoing
just want to thank everyone
listed here on the slide
and we also have
open positions in the group um as we're
continuing
these experiments and trying to really
help um
bring the ips technology into clinical
applications and drug discovery
um
yeah thank you very much for your
attention and i think we have
plenty of time for uh questions
thank you dr cengetch for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
are the components of the sept cocktail
commercially available
yes
we have uh detailed this in the
published um
paper uh so this was published in nature
methods um
this year in in may
uh yeah please take a look and um and
also feel free to reach out to me
directly i'm happy to
provide additional information and and
share how to
mix these four components um and we also
have already received um
really great feedback from from the
community and other groups using the
cocktail
great thank you
next question
i really enjoyed reading the paper and i
have been trying the sept combination
how did you deliver sept to the cells
sept seemed to be only soluble in dmso
so did you make a stock in dmso i.e 1000
times and then dilute to one time in
media
yeah so we have um a standardized
protocol that i can share um
so please
feel free to reach out to me so what we
typically do is um
so chrome and one embry cassan
and uh trans israel so we dilute this at
one to ten thousands
uh dilution actually
and um and the polyamine is a supplement
that
um it's
you basically dilute this and as one to
one thousand dilution
um and this is um
for us the most practical way of using
it so i i recommend
make stop solutions at one two
ten one two one top one to ten thousand
um
and and we also have a protocol that i
as i said happy to share
just said shoot me an email i i would
like to share this really with
with
the interested uh scientists here on the
on the
on the um on the chat
all right
great thank you
um our next question great talk and
thanks could you comment on the cost
except comparing to current rock
inhibitor
so as i showed in my previous slides
and this is also part of
supplemental material in the published
paper
um so it is cheaper it is um
even cheaper than y27632
alone
so those four components
um
fortunately turn out to be you know
cheaper so we this was not planned
initially but we were happy to see this
after we had completed um
developing the cocktail
so
yeah you definitely save some money on
on using set
great thank you
next question
have you used sept for culturing tissue
resident adult stem cells
um that's a great question uh so we
haven't done that specifically but i'm
i'm assuming that you will
i'm predicting you will see uh
beneficial effects uh so i know from a
colleague
um
who had basically um problems culturing
a cancer cell line uh so we think cancer
cell lines are easy to culture but some
cancer cell lines are actually
tricky and and and my colleague at ncats
then used sats at each passage uh
pathogen step
and and sep was really uh helping
and enable the group to to culture this
you know
finicky uh cancer cell line
um and as i
demonstrated in my presentation uh so
even commercially available
um differentiated cells uh like motor
neurons and and others that i've shown
cardiomyocytes they benefit from seps um
so we think it's probably
you know more universal um
beneficial effect for cells that are
exposed to cell culture stress
and um
so again
the more sensitive your cells are
the more you know the stronger the
effect of sep might be so this is really
uh what i think uh and with ips cells
you know these are particularly
sensitive cells so it was good really to
you know
tackle this one you know particularly
sensitive cell type
um but again now other cell types
i think would benefit from from this
discovery
um yeah please give it a try and let us
know how it works
great thank you
next question
can you describe your psc dissociation
protocol
um
[Music]
would you please repeat this again i i
want to
really make sure that i
understand the question well so so the
dissociation is that the question yes um
can you describe your psc
dissociation protocol
um
so
so if this question is related to single
cell dissociation
um
you know before we do the single cell
cloning so we typically use accutase
um
but i can i can double check so we have
tested various um
reagents but single-celled association
dissociation and accutase uh works best
in our hands
um but you have to again use sets
otherwise yeah you're you know you don't
get the the beneficial effects
all right great
next question
after single cell cloning what day did
you do media exchange can you leave the
cells undisturbed for longer eg
greater than three to four days
yeah
yeah that's also
really a great question
so we have a protocol paper
that we just submitted
but i can tell you
yeah this is
you know also described in in that
manuscript and so what we do is
so we don't we want to avoid
um
physical stress with an early media
change um so that's the reason why we um
typically culture cells routinely e8
medium for single cell cloning
we switch to stem flex
so which comes with the more stabilized
um fgf2 version
so this allows us to to actually
do the single cell dispensing
and then leave the cells alone for three
days typically for 72 hours
you don't do a media change and then
also um leave sept basically
uh
you know
exposed to the cells for three days and
this is
perfectly fine
and you can then do it media change at
day three and then and then you should
get um
you know really nice uh clone formation
after that
yeah
good point
great
next nice talk does set also work for
other cells like mscs or neural
progenitors
so
neural progenitors
yes we have tested that um
[Music]
but for mscs so we so my group doesn't
work on mscs we haven't tried that but
again
i would predict that you would see
beneficial effects
um
yeah and
as an example for the for the zika virus
experiment that i was briefly touching
on at the very beginning
um so we generated neural stem cells or
neuroprogenitors from ips cells
to do a genome-wide screen and and in
this case
uh sept was kind of
almost too good you basically couldn't
after you would um add zika virus
uh so this would even protect from from
zika virus
infection
uh so so it's essentially
uh
you have to sometimes
depending on your assay um
sep was was basically too much of a good
thing
and we had to you know develop an assay
that was um
that was only in the presence of of
chrome and juan in this case
but this is a particular case with this
experiment um
but neural stem cells neuroprogenitors
if you routinely culture them you want
to keep them undifferentiated and
self-renewing
uh stress-free
yeah absolutely i would i would
recommend using sept
great
next question
what's the difference to sort single
cells using this single cell dispensers
and flow cytometry
um so we think that
the the pressure of
you know
how you dispense the cells eventually so
so the instrument we are using here
has very low pressure um
microfluidics based
we think that that no no other facts uh
instrument that i know of has has this
kind of
gentle um
you know low pressure
um condition uh so so what we're trying
to do is we're using sats but we also
want to avoid any physical
stress or damage to the cells that can
occur if you if you essentially
um
you know
use maybe a fax machine that doesn't
come with this low pressure uh cell
dispensing uh technology
so so in that regards you know trying to
optimize as much as we can
so using sept you know combined with the
with
the
namo cell hana instrument turned out to
be really
um very practical as well so so the
instrument doesn't
take much time to set up and can be used
uh even you know very quickly and
sometimes now if fax machines
you know you have to go find someone who
is this particular training
uh
so the simplicity of using this
instrument was another um you know
important reason for us to to
yeah to develop this protocol around
this technology
great thank you
next question
do you use this sept cocktail just for
the beginning of sensory neuronal
differentiation as ri
or
you have to use them all the way from
the beginning to the end of
differentiation
for example eight weeks in their case
um
so again we're not using sept
like continuously right so as i said for
single cell
um for three days that's fine because
you don't want to
stress yourself with an early media
change
um so for sensory neuronal sensation you
basically have kind of a
stepwise differentiation process um so
what we do is so we have developed yeah
a different protocol actually
it's unpublished to to
differentiate ips cells into sensory
neurons or nociceptors
so it's a stepwise process and you have
to
first turn ips cells into neural crest
stem cells expressing salts 10
and then
you know you have to basically
you know do this in a stepwise fashion
and then cells go on and differentiate
into um
into sensory neurons so at every
passaging step or if you
you know at the very beginning start
with a defined number of cells so this
is also one approach we're taking so
every cell differentiation protocol
we're developing
we've been trying to avoid you know
overgrowing uh cells
so if you overgrow cells you have less
control
on their face and this also you know
comes with additional stress
um so don't over grow your cells uh try
to come up with a defined number of
cells that you want to first plate and
this is when when sept again becomes
important
because
you know
you're starting with
stress-free conditions
and then you differentiate the cells and
then when you have to passage
again
use
um the step cocktail
and in some cases
when you use again emerald body
formation or other approaches you set uh
typically for 24 hours
and then you you don't
you basically don't need
you know to expose the cells for longer
um because with every cassand we have a
pancake space inhibitor
and we don't want to you know
permanently
or for prolonged time
periods basically inhibit caspases
because if something goes wrong with
these cells
um
you know genetically karyotypically so
they should still
have the opportunity to undergo
apoptosis
and and so it's a reversible effect so
it's just 24 hours
exposure if you do this routinely
taking away
uh sets or every customer in this case
you you basically get back to the
regular
levels of of caspases
um
so so again 24 hours to 72 hours
depending on you know the assay or the
experiment you're doing but don't use it
kind of for multiple several weeks for
instance so that's that's really not
needed
thank you
next question
may your cocktail work for the cold
ischemia that is seen during the organ
harvest and transport
yeah that's a great question um we
haven't tried that but that was
something that we really thought that
could be an additional um
you know benefit
yeah you should give it a try
i wouldn't be surprised because yeah it
seems to really
um
you know take advantage of this this uh
poly pharmacology approach you know
we're not just
targeting just the
rock pathway um
but but taking care of multiple stress
mechanisms and and that was
or that's for us really the the key here
that
it's not enough just to um inhibit
rock kinase
but you have to take care of the other
uh things as well
great
um next question
why do you think single cell cloning
with sept is superior to other methods
yeah
so the reason is really that we're not
just interested in
one cell surviving this this procedure
right so so when you have one cell
that you treat it with you know the
current technologies and the cells of
eyes
that's obviously good news but but you
also know that this the cell was
stressed right during this first you
know
as we demonstrate
uh even in the first
couple of minutes
first hours
typically the stem cell you know field
would pass itself or do a certain
procedure and then they look at the
cells 24 hours later
but but the whole
stress that has happened
uh before that uh is is kind of
something that we have been
underestimating uh in the stem cell
field so we're thinking that you have to
really
take care of the stress from the very
beginning
so therefore the likelihood that the
cell that survived with your protocol
has undergone stress and
most likely dna double strand breaks and
then it repairs itself
so you're increasing the chance of of
getting genetic abnormalities
uh
again where sap is you know has a
cytoprotective effect so it's
essentially
a higher quality
or higher cell fitness that we think we
are promoting by using sept
yeah and i think mechanistically this is
kind of a new way of looking at these
cells um so back in the day we were just
happy when we would see cells survive 24
hours later
right but again now looking at these
early time points we see wow this is a
very significant amount of stress that
these cells
even if they decide to you know survive
and they're repeatedly exposed to this
particularly um when you do your routine
passaging
thank you
next question
do you think the method of cell sorting
or cell dispensing is important
yeah we think so with with facts um we
have tried various facts instruments we
think that
you know you have the additional
physical stress of dispensing the cells
and and
essentially you these are really fragile
sensitive cells and
the more gentle you can go about this
simply you know a better approach
um but also the speed is important um so
we're doing
lots of high throughput experiments and
we don't want to
leave these cells as as a suspension for
you know extended periods of time but
rather
single cells associate them and then
quickly dispense them
um and then obviously you want to put
these cells also back to 37 degrees etc
so this whole you know
time period is is very important uh and
again
you want
you want
to do this in a gentle way but you also
want the speed and the accuracy
wait well it looks like we have time for
one more question
do you see cell line to cell line
variability in the context of single
cell cloning
uh yes absolutely um so this is
something we cannot explain at this
point but this is obvious to many other
groups as well um so in some cases we
have eighty percent
single cell cloning efficiency
uh in some more difficult cell lines
we get sometimes numbers around 20
um but but in all instances these
numbers are higher when you use sets as
compared to y27
or clone r or other reagents so we
definitely
always have this improvement but that
yeah there's a range of of um there's a
variation across different cell lines in
terms of uh chronology chronologicity
clonal genesis acidity
or the
essentially
they are for whatever reason
inherently sensitive
um
and it's it's not well understood i
would say all together in the stem cell
field
all right well thank you dr singet do
you have any final comments for our
audience
um yeah i would like to thank again the
organizers and also the audience really
for um the great questions i think it
was really fun to
talk about these these
various uh interesting questions
appreciate that
well great well thank you again dr singh
for your time today in your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor namasel for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
bye everyone